I think there was some headline about
how in Japan people want to look at porn
more than they want to date or have sex
yeah and my friend said that's insane
could you imagine you got you got an
opportunity to sleep with a woman or to
look at porn could you imagine someone
choosing porn yeah and I said I totally
can understand that well yeah you I mean
speaking of that culture you go into a
place where you don't even have to
interact with a human person to get food
I mean we're living in a culture where
people don't want to pick up a phone and
call somebody it's only text or we want
to talk to a screen we don't want any
people have so much Social Anxiety so in
that culture yeah of course
the the porn is requires no effort is
never going to judge you there's no
rejection there's no rejection and the
porn can be whatever stuff you type in
you're gonna have like three furries and
an alien and whatever